[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: YES!
HAPPY, HAPPY WEDNESDAY.
IT REALLY IS A WONDERFUL
WEDNESDAY, WELL, UNLESS YOU
LIVE IN WASHINGTON D.C.
THEN YOU'RE SCREWED.
I MEAN, A NEARLY UNANIMOUS
MOVE, COUNCILMEMBERS IN THE
NATION'S CAPITOL VOTED TO
SOFTEN PENALTIES FOR VIOLENT
CRIMES INCLUDING CARJACKINGS,
MURDER AND SEXUAL ASSAULT!
THE UPSIDE?
WELL, NOW THE COURTS WON'T
HAVE TO DEAL WITH VIOLENT
OFFENDERS.
THEY COULD BE FREE TO
PROSECUTE GAS-OVEN OWNERS, AND
IT'S ABOUT TIME!
THE OVERALL CITY'S CRIMINAL
CODE INCLUDES REDUCED MAXIMUM
SENTENCES AND THE ELIMINATION
OF NEARLY ALL MANDATORY
MINIMUM SENTENCES.
THIS IS CRAZY!
THERE'S ALSO PROVISIONS THAT
LET VIOLENT CRIMINALS ASK FOR
EARLY RELEASE 20 YEARS INTO
THEIR SENTENCES IN CASE THEY
WERE TOO STUPID TO DEMAND THEY
GO TO THE WOMEN'S JAIL.
GROW YOUR HAIR OUT FOR GOD'S
SAKE.
SO IF YOU'RE IN A DRUG CARTEL,
MAYBE THAT MIGRANT BUS TAKING
TO YOU D.C. ISN'T SUCH A BAD
IDEA AFTER ALL.
THEY INITIALLY PASSED THIS
CODE IN NOVEMBER BUT DEMOCRAT
MAYOR MURIEL BOWSER VETOED IT.
LISTEN.
>> ANYTIME THERE'S A POLICY
THAT REDUCES PENALTIES, I
THINK IT SENDS THE WRONG
MESSAGE.
IT'S THE WRONG WAY TO GO.
>> Greg: HM.
HER INSURANCE MUST HAVE
APPROVED STEM CELL TREATMENTS
BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE SHE
FINALLY GREW A BRAIN.
MAYBE SHE COULD LEND IT TO OUR
PRESIDENT ON THE WEEKENDS.
BUT THIS IS THE SAME LADY
BEHIND THE CREATION OF BLM
PLAZA.
TRIP VISOR SAYS IT'S ONE --
ADVISER SAYS IT'S ONE OF THE
10 BEST STREETS FOR GETTING
BEATEN ON A BUDGET.
SHE VETOED GIVING CRIMINALS
FREE REIGN OF THE CITY BUT THE
LAST TIME I CHECKED, THUGS
WEREN'T EXACTLY BEING SENT TO
THEIR ROOM WITH NO SUPPER OF
THE SHE WAS OVERRULED THIS
WEEK BY THE COUNCIL WHICH
CLAIMS THEY'RE NOT HANDING OUT
HARSH PENALTIES ANY WAYS SO
LET'S GET RID OF THEM.
SO THE RULING MIGHT MAKE HER
LOOK MODERATE BUT REALLY SHE'S
AS CRAZY AS THEY ARE.
HERE IS HOW ONE COUNCILMAN
TRIED TO SPIN IT.
>> IT DOESN'T LESSEN THE
PENALTY.
IT LINES UP WITH WHAT THE
COURTS ARE HANDING OUT.
WHAT PEOPLE ARE LOOKING AT IS
ON D.C.'S CRIMINAL CODE, MANY,
MANY YEARS AGO, THERE WAS
SOMETHING ADDED THAT ADDED THE
POSSIBLE MAXIMUM AS UP TO 40
YEARS IN PRISON FOR AN ARMED
CARJACKING.
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THE
COURTS EVER HAND OUT.
IF ANYONE COULD EXPLAIN TO ME
WHAT HE SAID I'LL GIVE YOU A
LOLLIPOP AND A FOOT MASSAGE
RIGHT HERE RIGHT NOW.
TYRUS?
>> I DON'T WANT THOSE.
I'M JUST GOING KEEP IT TO
MYSELF.
>> Greg: OK!
BUT THIS IS A PENALTY FOR
ARMED CARJACKING, NOT HAVING
OVERDUE TAPES FROM BLOCKBUSTER
VIDEO.
THEY SHOULD ALL BE GETTING THE
40-YEAR MAXIMUM, THE SAME
PENALTY THEY USED AT
BLOCKBUSTER VIDEO.
>> ATTENTION, GUTFELD
DRIVERS...
>> Greg: TO THE PERSON WHO
WROTE THIS BLOCKBUSTER JOKE,
WHAT YEAR DO YOU THINK IT IS?
BLOCKBUSTER'S LAST STORE
CLOSED IN 2019.
LET'S TRY TO KEEP THE
REFERENCES TO THINGS THAT
ACTUALLY EXIST LIKE KISS MY
GRITS AND WHO SHOT J.R.?
I GET THOSE.
ANY WAY, IF THESE POLITICIANS
ARE SO WORRIED ABOUT
PROTECTING ARMED CARJACKERS,
AT LEAST CHANGE THE NAME TO
UNPLANNED HITCHHIKERS.
VIOLENT THUGS HAVE FEELINGS,
TOO.
SO WHY THIS CHANGE?
I MEAN, LOOK AT THE STATS ON
CARJACKINGS ALONE IN D.C.
IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS,
THEY'VE SKY ROCKETED.
148 BACK IN 2018 TO 485 LAST
YEAR.
THAT'S ONE FOR EVERY TWINKIE
AND A NAVARRO 8 IN THAT TIME
SPAN.
>> DAMN.
>> Greg: ALWAYS CLAP.
HAS ANYTHING BEEN DONE TO STOP
THIS?
NO!
THEY'RE ACTUALLY DOING THE
OPPOSITE!
APPARENTLY WOKE POLITICIANS
ONLY CARE ABOUT STOLEN CARS IF
THEY STILL RUN ON GAS.
SO SINCE YOU'RE A GUTFELD
VIEWER AND YOU'RE SMART AND
ASKING YOURSELF, "SELF, WHY
WOULD THE CITY COUNCIL THEN
WANT TO REDUCE PENALTIES FOR A
CRIME THAT'S EXPLODING?"
AND BECAUSE YOU'RE A GUTFELD
VIEWER AND YOU'RE SMART, YOUR
ANSWER WOULD BE, "BECAUSE
THEY'RE RETARDED!"
>> URGENT, A GUTFELD APOLOGY.
>> Greg: MY APOLOGIES FOR
USING A WORD NORMALLY USED FOR
DESCRIBING THE CAST OF "THE
VIEW."
BUT YOU HAVE TO WONDER WHY
THEY'D EASE PENALTIES FOR
VIOLENT CRIME.
IT'S ALL ABOUT CRIMINAL
REPARATIONS.
APPARENTLY WE MUST REDUCE
PENALTIES AGAINST VIOLENT
CRIME TO MAKE UP FOR YEARS OF
OPPRESSION.
YOU SEE, CRIMINALS ARE THE
VICTIMS AND THEY DESERVE
DAMAGES FOR MAKING THEM
CRIMINALS.
OF COURSE, THIS IS RACIST TO
ASSUME BLACKS OR ANY MINORITY
WOULD BE LIKE, "WOW, THANKS
GUYS!
YOU KNOW I WASN'T PLANNING TO
CARJACK SOMEONE, BUT NOW I
MIGHT BE!"
BECAUSE APPARENTLY THERE ARE
ONLY MINORITY CRIMINALS AND
NOT MINORITY VICTIMS.
THE D.C. ATTORNEY GENERAL
DOESN'T EVEN HIDE IT TWEETING,
"REFORMS TO D.C.'S
122-YEAR-OLD CRIMINAL CODE
PASSED BEFORE WOMEN AND BLACK
RESIDENTS ENJOYED FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS ARE SORELY NEEDED.
THIS BILL WILL IMPROVE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND PROVIDE LONG
OVERDUE CLARITY AND FAIRNESS
IN OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM."
I'M SURE THOSE WORDS WILL BE
COMFORTING AT THE FUNERAL WHEN
SOME BLACK OR HISPANIC PARENT
IS BURYING THEIR KID WHO WAS
MURDERED FOR HIS NISSAN.
IT'S NOT ABOUT SAFETY.
IT'S ABOUT RETROACTIVE EQUITY.
IF THEY WERE VICTIMS OF THE
PAST, YOU SHALL NOW BE VICTIMS
IN THE FUTURE.
THE NEW CRIM CODE DOESN'T EVEN
TABLING -- THE NEW CRIMINAL
CODE DOESN'T EVEN TAKE EFFECT
UNTIL 2025.
SO IF YOU LIVE OUT IN
WASHINGTON D.C., GET OUT RIGHT
NOW IN YOUR CAR INSTEAD OF
LATER IN A HEARSE.
>> HERE HE IS...
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME
TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
HE'S HAD MORE PEOPLE KILLED
THAN THE CLINTONS, FORMER CIA
OPERATIVE AND AUTHOR OF THE
NEW BOOK "COMPANY RULES," MIKE
BAKER!
[APPLAUSE]
HIS SHOWS ARE LIKE A BARREL OF
MONKEYS.
THEY STINK AND ARE FULL OF
PARASITES.
ACTOR AND COMEDIAN AND WRITER
JAMIE.
SHE'S JUST LIKE A CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENT OFTEN FOUND ON THE
FLOOR NEXT TO AN OLD CAR.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT
TIMPF.
[APPLAUSE]
AND FINALLY, HE EATS HIS
DINNER OFF TECTONIC PLATES.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK AND THE
NWA WORLD HEAVYWEIGHT CHAMPION
TYRUS.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE, FIRST, CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR NEW BOOK.
HERE TO TELL US WHAT IT'S
ABOUT?
>> YES, I WOULD, AND THANK YOU
FOR ASKING IN THIS.
IT'S CALLED "COMPANY RULES."
IT'S ON THE SCRIBD PLATFORM
WHICH IS THE NETFLIX OF BOOKS,
AS YOU KNOW.
>> Greg: I DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
>> THE WHOLE IDEA IS -- LOOK,
IT'S AN AUDIO BOOK.
I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH BIG WORDS
TO WRITE AN ACTUAL BOOK,
RIGHT?
BUT THE GOOD NEWS FOR THE
VIEWING AUDIENCE IS THAT I
NARRATE IT MYSELF.
>> THAT WAS MY QUESTION.
YEAH.
>> EXACTLY.
AND IT'S VERY SOOTHING.
>> Greg: YEAH, EVEN THOUGH
YOU SAY ALMOST NOTHING AND
YOUR SENTENCES ARE A JUMBLED
MESS OF INCOHARNESS, IT'S
STILL SOOTHING -- INCOHERENT,
IT'S STILL SOOTHING.
>> THAT'S WHAT MY KIDS SAY ALL
THE TIME.
IT'S NOT ABOUT MY TIME IN THE
CIA.
IT'S WHAT HAPPENED WHEN I GOT
OUT OF THE AGENCY, WITH A
LIMITED SET OF SKILLS,
CERTAINLY NOT BUSINESS-WISE,
STARTED AND KEPT A BUSINESS
MOVING.
THERE WERE CERTAIN PRINCIPLES
I TOOK AWAY WITH ME FROM MY
CIA DAYS THAT HELPED ME NOT
ONLY IN BUSINESS BUT IN LIFE.
>> Greg: I DIDN'T ASK WHAT
THE BOOK WAS ABOUT.
>> DO I HAVE TIME?
>> Greg: THANK YOU,
EVERYBODY.
BE SURE TO WATCH -- NO.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS BEHIND
THIS?
DO YOU THINK MY THEORY IS
CORRECT?
PLEASE SAY YES.
>> I HONESTLY DO I CAN'T PUT
THIS ANY SIMPLER.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE CONSEQUENCES
FOR ACTIONS, YOU WILL HAVE
INCREASED CRIME.
IF YOU DENIGRATE THE POLICE,
YOU'LL HAVE INCREASED CRIME.
THAT'S AS SIMPLE AS IT GOES.
AND I USED TO LIVE IN D.C.
YEARS AGO FOR A BRIEF PERIOD
OF TIME.
IT WAS POORLY RUN THEN.
IT'S POORLY RUN NOW.
MAYOR BOWSER TRIED TO -- WHO
BY THE WAY I LOVED ON SHANANA
-- TRIED TO DO THE RIGHT THING
-- THAT WAS QUITE THE CULTURAL
PULL --
>> Greg: THREE PEOPLE GOT
THAT JOKE AND THEY'RE THROWING
UP.
>> NO.
HOW MANY PEOPLE GOT THAT JOKE?
RIGHT?
A LOT.
YES!
[APPLAUSE]
YOU ASKED.
>> Greg: I SHOULDN'T HAVE
ASKED.
GET TO THE POINT, MIKE.
>> MY POINT IS EVEN IN THE
CITY WHERE THE MAYOR --
>> HE'S STILL TALKING!
>> YEAH, I KNOW.
>> DID I TELL YOU ABOUT MY
BOOK.
>> I WENT AWAY AND CAME BACK
AND YOU WERE STILL TALKING.
>> THE BOOK IS 47 HOURS JUST
SO YOU KNOW.
>> NOW YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE
LIVING WITH ME.
I'M DONE.
>> Greg: OK.
JAMIE, DOES THIS INSPIRE YOU
TO TAKE UP CARJACKING?
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH A ROUGH PERIOD RIGHT
NOW.
I THINK YOU'RE ACTUALLY LIVING
IN A CAR.
SO --
>> YEAH, HONEST TO GOODNESS,
CARJACKING SCARES ME, JUST THE
WHOLE IDEA OF IT.
IT SCARES ME SO MUCH I
FASHIONED MY CAREER TO NEVER
BE ABLE TO AFFORD A NICE CAR.
>> Greg: THAT'S GOOD.
GOOD FOR YOU.
>> I'M SO WORRIED ABOUT IT.
BECAUSE YOU NEVER HEARD OF A
BUS JACKING.
>> Greg: NO.
THAT'S TRUE.
THAT IS TRUE.
>> I SAW A BUS JACKING ONCE
BUT IT'S A DIFFERENT KIND OF
-- UM.
[CHUCKLES]
I CAN SAY ONE QUICK THING
ABOUT BLOCKBUSTER VIDEO?
>> Greg: SURE.
>> DO YOU KNOW THAT THE VERY
LAST STANDING BLOCKBUSTER
VIDEO IS IN FACT WHERE I LIVED
IN FAIRBANKS, ALASKA.
THAT'S TRUE.
THE LAST TIME I WENT IN THERE,
IT WAS THE REMAKE OF
GHOSTBUSTERS THAT CAME OUT.
IT WAS UP ON THE SHELF ON NEW
RELEASES -- REMEMBER THAT?
THEY SAID, IF YOU LIKE THIS,
YOU'LL ALSO LIKE... AND THERE
WAS AN ARROW POINTING TO A
BOWL OF [BLEEP]
[CHUCKLING]
>> Greg: I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU
TOOK A REFERENCE ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT DOES THIS AND
THEN YOU DID A JOKE ON IT
BECAUSE YOU HAD IT ON THE
LITTLE BACK OF YOUR BRAIN.
YEAH, I HAVE A JOKE ABOUT
BLOCKBUSTER.
THAT IS WHAT YOU DID.
>> I FEEL LIKE YOU COULD READ
MY MIND.
>> Greg: NO ONE LIKES A JOKE
ABOUT CRIME, KAT.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
THIS IS CRAZY.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS THE
RADICAL PUNISHMENT OF A
SOCIETY THEY BELIEVE DESERVES
IT?
>> I THINK CARJACKING IS BAD.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
[CHUCKLING]
>> I MEAN, THERE'S -- I THINK
THAT THERE'S PLENTY OF LAWS ON
THE BOOKS THAT, YOU KNOW,
PUNISH PEOPLE FOR DOING
SOMETHING THAT MAYBE ONLY
HURTS THEMSELVES.
CARJACKING IS NOT ONE OF
THOSE.
I DON'T THINK ABOUT A
CARJACKING.
I'M NOT, OH NO, I HOPE THAT
PERSON THAT DID IT GETS TO
COME OUTSIDE AGAIN SOON.
I DON'T KNOW THAT ANYBODY IS
OUT THERE THINKING ABOUT THIS.
SO I THINK THAT NO MATTER WHAT
YOU THINK ABOUT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE, YOU HAVE TO BE
AGAINST WHEN IT COMES TO
VIOLENT CRIMES, BECAUSE
EITHER, YOU KNOW, IT'S GOING
TO BE VIOLENCE ALL OVER THE
PLACE BUT EVENTUALLY THEN
MAYBE THAT PENDULUM WILL SWING
IN ANOTHER DIRECTION AND WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A SUPER, SUPER
STRICT POLICE STATE.
NOBODY SHOULD BE PRO-VIOLENCE
EXCEPT FOR CRIMINALS
THEMSELVES WHICH WE SHOULDN'T
BE CATERING TO.
>> Greg: YEAH, YOU KNOW, BUT
THE THING IS TYRUS -- THERE
ISN'T -- THERE HAS TO BE A
REASON FOR THIS.
IF EVERY SENSIBLE PERSON SEES
THIS AS NUTS AND YET THEY
UNANUSLY VOTE FOR IT --
UNANIMOUSLY VOTE FOR IT, WHAT
ARE WE MISSING?
IF YOU DO THE COGNITIVE
EMPATHY AND PRETEND YOU'RE
THEM, WHAT ARE THEY THINKING?
>> THEY EXPLAIN THE WRONG
THINGS.
THEY SAY ARMED CARJACKING.
NO KIDDING YOU NEED ARMS TO
JACK A CAR.
THAT'S PRETTY BASIS.
YOU CAN'T -- YOU KNOW, IF YOU
HAVE A PISTOL IN YOUR HAND,
PEOPLE WILL GET OUT OF IT.
THAT SHOULD BE THE KEY THING.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT VERY
SPECIFIC CARJACKING THAT
THEY'RE REDUCING THE TIME FOR.
I MEAN, SOMEBODY PUTS A GUN IN
YOUR FACE AND SAYS, "GET OUT!"
AND YOU BETTER MAKE SURE THE
TANK'S AT LEAST HALF FULL
BECAUSE HOW IRRITATING WOULD
THAT BE IF YOU JACKED A CAR
AND YOU HAD TO GAS UP.
>> YES!
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT I'M
SAYING?
WHAT IT IS IS LIKE WHEN I WAS
A CHILD, YOU HAD TO MAKE
CHOICES.
YOU WOULD SAY, "MOMMY.
I WANT TO BE AN OUTLAW."
SHE SAID, "NO, IF YOU BECOME
AN OUTLAW, YOU'LL GO TO JAIL."
NOW IT'S LIKE, "MOMMY, I WANT
TO BE AN OUTLAW."
YOU CAN STEAL CARS, BUILD A
CAREER, PHOTOPHASEBOOK AND
BECOME A CARJACKING INFLUENCER
AND BE -- PUT IT ON FACEBOOK
AND BECOME A CARJACKING
INFLUENCER AND BE FINE.
>> THE LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS OF
WASHINGTON D.C. ARE
UNANIMOUSLY AGAINST THIS MOVE.
THE CRIMINALS LOVE IT.
IT SERVES NO PURPOSE.
I WAS JUST SITTING HERE
THINKING ABOUT YOUR POINT --
AND YOU'RE RIGHT, THERE'S NO
LOGICAL REASON WHY THEY'RE
PUSHING THIS.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHY IT HAS
TO BE A PUNITIVE, SYMBOLIC
KIND OF THING.
>> UNEFFECTED PEOPLE -- LIKE
WHEN YOU SAW HIM IN THIS
LITTLE INTERVIEW SAFE IN HIS
OFFICE, HE'S SAYING, OH,
MEANWHILE THE MAYOR HAS
EXPERIENCED SOME FORM OF
CARJACKING OR SOMEONE IN HER
FAMILY OR SOMEONE SHE KNOWS,
THE UNEFFECTED OR EFFECTED.
AS PROGRESSIVE AS SHE IS, SHE
DOESN'T WANT ANY MORE
CARJACKINGS.
SHE'S SAYING THIS IS BAD.
IT HASN'T HAPPENED TO THAT
GROUP YET AND THEY PROBABLY
DON'T LIVE IN THE CITY.
>> Greg: THEY NEED TO FEEL
THE CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR
POLICIES.
IT'S LIKE WHEN THE BUSES TOOK
THE MIGRANTS TO THE CITIES.
GET THESE CRIMINALS TO WHERE
THESE PEOPLE LIVE SO THEY KNOW
WHAT IT'S LIKE.
THAT GUY IS THE POSTER CHILD,
THE BETA-MALE WHITE
PROGRESSIVE.
>> I KNEW IT WAS GOING TO BE A
WHITE